i think as far as i know it was brian
kernington and dennis ritchie who first
introduced it to me
i don't know if it goes back earlier
than that but certainly in in the c
book there it is printf hello world you
know
and the use of backslash n to denote a
new line at the end of it and all that
it's now really become a part of comps
our legend the first thing you do when
you show
that you've mastered a new language be
it python or whatever you know yes
oh yes here's how to do hello world
of course hello world is a
character's based challenge and from
what we now know about
characters in modern computers at least
been stored in addressable bites
does it sort of follow then that hello
world would be
somewhat easier on a bike-based machine
oh yes it will be a lot
easier on a bike-based machine but
there's other things as well
so as perhaps an illustration of just
how
horrible it could be and given that we
have done some
stuff on edsack already
let's go and do that if you haven't seen
the other headset stuff i think you'll
be able to follow what i'm doing anyway
and you could always go back later
and pick up some more background about
ed sack but
when we were on this ed sac simulator
the last time we actually did run
the program that martin campbell kelly
supplies with it
and he got fed up of doing hello world
he said i'll just do a brief version
which says hi
we did that thanks to a combined
programming effort now
by those in this room i have here
the new version hello world srdfb.text
and there it is
it's quite a lot longer of course than
the previous one was
so is each of those lines using a word
then yes
edsack was designed around the most
minimalist
set of things it was basically the story
was if it's possible to do with what
we've got already
don't start inventing new flavors of
instructions
so all you've got here is this is the
stuff of course for setting up
where the load point is and where the
relative offsets of these addresses is
relative to 64.
the at symbol at the end signals to
david
wheeler's initial orders that what comes
here is a relative address
so what it's saying is letter o not a
zero
output the character
which you will find in the memory
location 16
further on than 64 is
so all these offsets 16 17 18 19
20 are all relative to 64. so in actual
fact then it turns out
that address 80 holds the very first
thing you want to output and of course
16 on from 64 well if 64 is here
this is where the actual data starts the
zf
and the things like that correspond to
what are nowadays called assembler
directives
it's not always the case that these
things go
one for one into occupying a word some
of them are messages to the assembler
all this stuff up here is basically
saying i want you to remember 64
and start locating everything relative
to that
because if we looked specifically at the
line numbers on the left there
that wouldn't be the place you're trying
to get into right no
this stuff up here is what would
probably be
done in modern assemblers by saying
something like org equals 64.
in other words that isn't a program
instruction it's telling you the
assembler please start me at 64. and
it's for your own internal knowledge
it's not to be translated into a program
instruction so
the zf says stop stop execution
but in the meantime what we're expecting
is that the thing that is 16 on
from 64 will actually get us to here
for star f what does star ref do star is
a
short code for saying put yourself in
letter shift
veterans of five-hole paper tape well no
you've got to make sure that you're in
letter shift to print meaningful
messages
the other possible shift is figure shift
and
all hell breaks loose if you start
forgetting
to shift out it's just like the shift
key on a typewriter that's where it
comes from historically
can you use that as a very very
simplistic code yeah
yes possibly um anyway so turn into
letter shift and look
this makes sense now can you see h f in
one word of single length word f
means this is a single length word yeah
18 bits
actually the op code field for those
who've got the headset tutorial
the obco op code field is occupied by an
h but the o command
will output these as if
they were characters and meant to be
characters they've got to be in the
opcode field
but the o command says look in the
opcode field regard it
as not a bordeaux character remember
maurice wilkes had invented ed sac code
it's subtly different but never mind and
it's so you end up
coming to say oh it's the letter h i am
to
output with this o instruction with a
relative address
offset on it and you go all the way look
here h-e-l-l-o
what's exclamation mark look it up in
the edsack tutorial as i had to do
that's the marker you put in if you want
to force an explicit space
between hello and world which we did and
we finally what
about at f and ampersand f after the d
of hello world well let's take a guess
we're trying to be neat and tidy make it
look good
that's the code for give me a carriage
return give me a line feed and then we
say
end of the whole thing end execution and
this is a marker also to
initial orders you can stop relocating
this program for me i'm done
okay so that since it's on top now
oh fingers crossed on what do we do we
do start don't we
we noticed that way back up at the top
we put in
a stop just to make sure because with
our incredible knowledge of headstock
binary sean and i can see straight away
that that of course is hello world isn't
it
i mean we're not kidding david wheeler
would know that i said hello world
i'll tell you something else sean after
only half a day's familiarity with this
john von neumann would know that that
was hello world
he found it so comfortable to remember
the details of the binary
you know i'm sure we would i really do
so here we go then let's do a single ep
single instruction single shot it's
sometimes called nowadays
right there we are it's still blinking
we turned into letter shift
with that click next click h oh isn't
this wonderful
aren't we demon programmers e l
l o space yes w
o r l d carriage return
line feed so that was pretty painful
although the t64k gives you
relocatability you could change that to
be t256k say if you wanted to
shove the whole thing up memory and then
maybe turn it into a subroutine
you want to push it somewhere else in
memory so the bulk relocation
against the base address is taken care
of by initial orders but you've still
got to get the offsets right and it's
painful it's utterly utterly painful
we're now going to jump forward into
safe bite addressed
territory for handling characters and
the arm 32-bit arm chip
which we use for teaching assembler
programming here to our first years um
yeah it is a 32-bit word
broken up into four bytes eight bit
bytes which of course use
ascii not ibm stick
fine so down at the assembler level
though for the arm then
what does the bite addressability give
us
and what other things have happened
between the edsak era
and this era where we're talking late
80s 90s this sort of thing
what else has happened to make this
thing so much more compact
so much easier to understand and so much
more flexible well let's go here through
step by step
comments anything after a semicolon is a
comment i put a comment up at the top
saying to put out the hello world we've
used the
so-called software interrupts the system
calls as provided by the university of
manchester's
komodo arm development environment which
is what we use
so when we get to actually printing the
character out don't get
worried by swi i mean software interrupt
to ask the operating system to print
something for me or something like that
so let's start up here programs on the
arm will cheerfully
expect if you don't tell them otherwise
that they will start executing at line
one of your program and go
madly on i put this data for hello world
up at the top
of the listing not at the bottom as i
could have done
but the rule then is if i declare hello
world here
as being a piece of text and this def
b here means just define a bunch of
bytes
and you put them in quotes like you
would in c and even taking over
some of its story from c it even allows
you to ask for a new line
to be put in there with massage n and
the only difference is whereas c
implicitly plugs its
strings with a null character at the end
arm
doesn't do that for you you must
explicitly put in a null character at
the end of your
string if that is your stop indicator
but in order to stop the arm chip
executing hello world as if it was big
pants for instructions which you don't
want you want to jump past it
i put in here look an unconditional
branch domain
branch domain oh now this is wonderful
you don't have to say branch to an
absolute address and be like david
wheeler and john
neumann and have them all in your head
you just say let's label it
maine and this thing called an assembler
will work out what main means in terms
of the address you want to jump to
isn't that wonderful von neumann stares
at you and says
that's for the weak brain who can't keep
track of their addresses you know
anyway so we branch to maine and the
first thing it says very
self-evidently really is get me
the start address of the text string and
put that start address into register one
next thing we notice as long promised
modern cpus have 15 or 16 special
purpose registers
to make life bearable exact didn't it
only had the accumulator
and if you wanted other storage places
you had to start parking it in memory in
all sorts of horrible ways so that helps
us straight away
r1 is going to be our so-called index
register it's going to start
off by pointing at
the address of h now i don't know what
the byte address of h
is it might even be relatively zero here
is the first thing that happens
in this program but whatever it is the
actual byte address of h
is now in register one here is the crux
of the whole thing
ldr byte load
into a register the byte specified as
follows
here i say r0 that's the register i want
to load it into
but where does it come from in square
brackets r1
that says look in r1 and you will find
an address
of the start of that string i don't want
you to load the address
into r0 i want you to load the character
that is at that address
into our xero it's in direction and that
is indicated
by that square bracket not putting the
address
that's in r1 into r0
and following the pointer from r1 and
say oh that's the letter h at the moment
and that's what i put into our zero
and here's the other cute thing at the
end wouldn't those pioneers have given
the world for this
is to say and when you've done that
please for next
time around the loop increment that
r1 address by one so if it was pointing
at 18 shall we say to start with it's 19
now for next time around the loop
so you keep on going around that loop
and here's the thing where you check
whether you've hit the null character
compare the contents of register zero
which will be a character contents
against literally zero
which is what the null character is now
is the answer yes or no
is it equal or not equal to zero and
here's another lovely thing
about the uh arm chip that steve and i
love dearly
this is the 32-bit arm chip i think in
the 64-bit one they've
it's not so important to do it nowadays
they have a thing in the 32-bit one
called conditional execution
which can save you often using a branch
instruction which are relatively
expensive
in pipeline terms so here we've got
swine which is wonderful
software interrupt zero says punch out
this character for me on the display on
the screen but any
says but do that only if the last thing
you did
didn't yield equal not equal
well we're checking for the null
character so as long as it
wasn't the null character it'll say no
i'm not equal to the null character
and you print it out and out it comes
character by character
after that of course you loop back to
go around and print another character
remembering that the hash one has
incremented your address pointer
along that string so you keep on going
around here you don't have to remember
what address
loop is you don't know the assembler
knows it fixes it up for you and then
right at the very end the way to say
stop execution i've done it swiping
flavor 2 on this emulated environment
says stop it completely
the development of that from
edsack you think oh my god i am so
pleased i've got that
and martin the inventor of the ed sax
administer here
i emailed him the other day and he came
back to me and said yes
the need for an index register was
realized so
quickly that that's why my emulator is
early 49 to latest 1950
because in late 1950 david will and
everybody say
my golly we need an index register and
they built one in
so in a way then this is what is
happening it's that
the pioneers were using their early
machinery
to lead the way and to say what extra
facilities
do we need to make life tolerable for us
now there is the hardware facility of
having the index registers and they'd be
just become standard kit after this
every out of time inject registers
but also what interests me is the role
of a proper assembler
initial orders 2 is not a full-blown
assembler
it helps you a little bit by turning
decimal addresses into binary but you
have to remember
that that letter a that you put in the
leading five bits could be the character
a
but if you're regarding this is an
instruction that's an ad instruction
so but then initial orders to
is relocating it's relocating doing a
bit of binary translation
it's a single pass process it's
wonderful
the problem with assembler is it has to
be a two-pass process
the trouble always is that labor if you
jump back to labels you've already seen
you will know already what address that
will be
because when you jump forward how do i
know where the heck that label down
there's going to be
i don't even want to calculate it i want
the assembly to say oh
i'm on location 186 now how handy
but then it can't fix up the addresses
till it knows
and has counted its way through the
program so then it says right
i will now output you a definitive thing
that you can put in
through david wheeler's initial orders
too
because i've made it so much easier for
you because i've allowed
labels one doesn't think of labels as
being a structuring convention and yet
at this low level they are in a way
because
this is saying loop it starts here
another label oh it ends here please
calculate the addresses of
of what's happening there and fix it up
for me and so you might say well
all right didn't everybody say we must
have assemblers it's the modern way to
do things
there were very mixed views about this
and i don't think headset got an
assembly until headset two
when another friend of mine david
hartley did i think a macro assembler
for exact two
not exact one because the story here
related to von neumann as well i don't
know whether it was
his ed vac or his version of edvac he
had in his basement called joniac
apparently who really berated a grad
student
who wrote an assembler assemblers for
the weak
brained who cannot work out their own
addresses
you do realize that in running this
assembler of yours
punching out a paper tape i'm behind you
in the queue
i don't get my turn next you come to me
and say ah but this is ready
to load now in the second phase
binary you're wasting time if you're so
weak brained you can't program me in
absolute
i'm putting words in his mouth but this
was essentially it
he no doubt had dreams in absolute
binary there was no problem
with john von neumann about coping as
close to binary as possible
he could keep it all in his head and he
would i think have found initial orders
on headset
about yes nice and helpful single pass
not slowing down things enough
but an assembler you're wasting time on
this machine
by doing assemblers i mean
it's really really brings it home
to those of us who always joked about
you know real programmers use assembler
the answer from certainly from john von
neumann possibly even from david willer
but he wouldn't have been as extreme as
that is
real programmers use absolute binary
as he talks about having the ultimate
laptop and in fact when he means the
ultimate laptop he's not talking about
the limit this is the important thing
there's the engineering limits
and then there's the pure physical
limits his ultimate laptop
is a plasma at um just a
at a stupidly high temperature